This is the new Sadaqah Jariyah in town.
We are teaching people how to pray. And
every time they pray, you get to share
in that reward. [music] And when they
teach their children and their
children's children
the reward continues. Every Fajr Dhuhr
Asr Maghrib Isha Tarawih
>> [music]
>> Tahajjud Every recitation you share in
the reward. For just £100
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people 90
learn how to pray salah. Donate today.
Donate today. Donate today.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Uh Ramadan Mubarak inshallah. I
hope Ramadan is going well for you guys.
So, has Saudi lied to us? Has the Saudi
regime conned us? Have they told us a
lie? Are we fasting when we shouldn't be
fasting? Are all these going to waste?
Well, these are all the questions that
people have. So, this is a graph of the
map, [snorts] actually. And this shows
that that red line in there is moon
sighting only visible with a telescope.
Okay, with something that you can see
uh with a telescope or something along
those lines in those regions. So,
they're saying the Saudi uh Saudi uh
Arabia is far, far away. So, it is
impossible. So, we're going to watch a
couple of videos inshallah and see the
claims inshallah and see inshallah if
your Ramadan is visible or not visible.
And subhanallah, we're just going to put
this uh
matter to bed with uh with Sheikh Uthman
Farooq, inshallah. So, let's watch
inshallah because this is getting really
ridiculous. People that would not even
think that would say that are now like
conspiring on conspiracy like Muhammad
bin Salman like, "What's he going to get
out of um
starting Ramadan a day earlier or
whatever it is for that matter?" So,
let's go to the first video, inshallah.
Let's see uh what the Muslims have to
say. I can't believe that people are
just arguing about this, inshallah.
Okay, let's go. BREAKING NEWS, SAUDI
ARABIA GOT THE MOON. BRO, WHY ARE YOU
SHOUTING? Audhu billahi min ash-shaytani
rajim, bro. It's Ramadan.
Why are you screaming and shouting like
that? What I found it
What's wrong with you? Habibi, what's
going on?
Why are you screaming like that? It's
like saw the moon like the way you
started it's like you almost thought you
saw the Dajjal. You saw the Antichrist
like you saw the Dajjal or subhanallah
some some kind of creature. sighting
wrong. Many people across the world are
saying Saudi Arabia may have gotten the
moon sighting wrong and that it was
apparently impossible to see the moon
and we should follow local moon sighting
like Morocco and other countries.
However, Saudi Arabia is saying they had
clear proof that the moon was sighted.
So, we should not be starting moon wars.
If you follow global, follow it. If you
follow local moon sighting, follow.
Please don't start moon wars this year
and let me know what day is your first
Ramadan. Habibi, you start it with a
madness like somebody you saw the
Dajjal. And at first and you saw it very
calm.
Anyways, let's move on to another video
inshallah. Let's see what this person
had to say.
>> Breaking news, SAUDI ARABIA GOT THE MOON
SIGHTING FOR RAMADAN WRONG. MUSLIMS ALL
ACROSS THE WORLD ARE SAYING SAUDI ARABIA
GOT THE MOON SIGHTING WRONG AND RAMADAN
ACTUALLY STARTS on Thursday. They are
also SAYING IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO SEE the
moon and we should follow local moon
sighting like Morocco. However, there
was proof that Saudi did see THE MOON.
GUYS, WALLAHI PLEASE LET'S NOT START
moon wars this year. IF YOU FOLLOW SAUDI
LIKE ME, THEN FOLLOW SAUDI. If you
follow local moon sighting, then follow
local moon sighting. And Allah knows
best. Share it.
>> Exactly. There you go. To the point,
okay. You know, obviously there was you
know, his the brother was a little bit
vocal alhamdulillah as well. But, you
know, he's not like the other guy the
guy acted like he's going to the angel
of death came. Okay, and so this is
another person from coming from a
different perspective and then we're
going to check out brother who explained
this matter inshallah. Okay. Saudi
Arabia today have announced that they've
seen the moon for Ramadan even though
it's scientifically impossible to have
seen the moon today and yet they've
announced it. Now, you can check this
for yourself. Go and check out HM
Nautical Almanac Office which is
historically related to the Royal
Observatory Greenwich. They say it's
impossible. There's multiple Arab
astronomy organizations saying it's
impossible including the Sharjah Academy
for Astronomy Science and Technology.
Including the government of Oman who a
few days ago declared that they would
not accept any moon sighting claims
today because it's scientifically not
possible to see the moon anywhere in the
Middle East or to be honest anywhere in
the world today. And yet Saudi
announced.
Now, many mosques in the UK follow
Saudi, and that's why many people will
be fasting tomorrow with Saudi on
Wednesday the 18th. But, many people
don't follow Saudi. Like us, we'll be
looking for the moon tomorrow. And
inshallah, if we see the moon tomorrow
at the observatory at Greenwich, we will
commence our fast on Thursday, the 19th
of February. Okay. So, now
okay, that's fine. You can follow your
Nobody is asking that you have to follow
Saudi. It's not a must. You can follow
your own region. We have Hadith from the
Prophet about this. Now, I will put this
all matter to bed. I will just leave it
to him. Here's the video, brothers and
sisters, and I'll give my little two
piece of which That's not even needed.
It's The fact that we're bickering about
this kind of stuff, etc. We don't look
at the bigger picture. We act like
bunnies right. When told him
sacrifice a cow. Which cow? What color?
When? How? This, that. They just made
matters so complicated for themselves.
And some people go to OCD. Some people
have these OCDs. And what I like they
got the priorities mixed up. Do you know
what I'm trying to say? Like, go and oh,
is my meat slaughtered in the right way?
Was the Imam, the person who slaughtered
it, was he praying Fajr? Did he say
Bismillah? Like,
like they go into details. And then
sometimes you see people like that who
go into like
details. There's nothing else in the
detail. You look at all this other stuff
when it comes to wronging people, when
it comes to not paying debts, etc. They
don't give a crap. And then you think,
bro, if you gave the effort over there,
it would have been better for you. But,
let's see what
I have to say. And I think this puts the
matter into bed. The Saudi moon sighting
a hoax?
Ya Allah, what is this nonsense people
are talking? Understand this. The
Prophet
told us, "When you sight the moon, fast.
When you sight the moon, break the
fast." It's simple.
Look, why would Saudi Arabia hoax a moon
sighting? You think they just want to
fast an extra day? No. Saudi Arabia has
official sites with observatories where
scholars, scientists, astronomers, they
all go out there to check for the moon.
In Tumair, they have this in the middle
of the desert. They have a beautiful
facility. They went out and they sighted
the moon. And they took pictures of it.
Not just one site, four different sites
have pictures of the moon that was
sighted.
I don't understand what's wrong with
people. They said they sighted it.
The Prophet
told us that when you hear somebody who
gives the testimony that they sighted
the moon, they fast. In the Hadith Sunan
Abi Dawud 2342, Abdullah ibn Umar said,
"The people went out to sight the moon,
they didn't see it. I saw it." The
Prophet
on just the testimony of Abdullah ibn
Umar, he began the month of Ramadan. So,
what is the issue here? And again, it's
not just one site, it's four different
sites across Saudi Arabia that have
taken pictures and posted them. And it's
not just Saudi Arabia. There were local
moon sightings in the UAE, in Qatar, in
Bahrain, in Kuwait, in Yemen, and in
Palestine. The Palestinian Authority
also declared it. In Gaza, you think the
people of Gaza are lying to us? They
sighted the moon. In Lebanon, in Sudan,
in Somalia, in the Djibouti, in South
Sudan, and even in Afghanistan. Yes, the
Taliban regime in Afghanistan, across
Afghanistan, sighted the moon and they
are fasting as well. You think they're
just blindly following Saudi? No, they
have their own moon sightings that they
saw across Afghanistan. This is
ridiculous. People making accusations
that have no basis. The moon was
sighted, you should be fasting. If you
didn't, that's between you and Allah,
but stop making baseless accusations.
There are pictures, the moon was
sighted, not by some random person, in
observatory across Saudi Arabia and
across the Muslim world. Allahuma
taqabbal minna wa minkum Ramadan
Mubarak. So, subhanallah, you can see
subhanallah the fact that Muhammad is
mentioned Abdullah ibn Umar saw a
sighting. And the Prophet took his word
and said, "If you've said it, you're a
believer." He didn't go to the
nitty-gritty, "Are you sure? This doubt,
we don't know."
Wallahi, we make the religion so hard on
ourselves. And if you look at Bani
Israel, the reason why the Jews have 600
plus commandments is because they made
life so hard for them self that
sometimes they even some of them have to
find loopholes in their religion so they
do not do certain things. They made it
harder on them self. Why are you making
life harder on them self? Even if it
started like I follow the Saudi
Saudi moon sighting. Okay, I'm not going
to come and say that oh my gosh I fasted
extra day. No.
Every action is based on its intention
guys. Even when it comes to this one
says it's given in charity there was
this whole thing that happened with the
charity sector scandal etc. Brothers and
sisters, your deeds are accepted. Okay,
if somebody misused your charity
whatever that's their fault. And you
shouldn't be reckless with this. The
same with this. Just know for example if
you go and eat any meat that's not halal
by accident. Stop bugging out. It
happened you're not to blame. Okay.
Subhanallah. So be understanding and be
careful with this and don't go into
ridiculous stuff. Use the month of
Ramadan. Do Look, do tasbih of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala. Okay, download the
Salah Pro app it's free. No ads no
subscription. Do your azkar. Do your
tasbih daily. Pray your salah if you're
not praying salah. Do acts of charity.
Okay, do acts of charity wherever you
want to donate inshallah. I will tell
you to donate to our cause teaching
people how to pray salah. Simple
donation of 100 pounds teaches 20 to 60
people to learn salah with the Quran. So
donate to whatever you want inshallah.
Do that act of charity. Do tasbih. Do
Quran. Do little acts. Forget about moon
sighting this that. Every intention
action is based on its intention. If
your reward action if your intention
were in the right place, do that. Not oh
my gosh I did that etc. Subhanallah if
you do the moon sighting in your local
country, do that. It is halal. Nobody
can force you. But to make a conspiracy
now, what are you going to say next?
Subhanallah. Yes, what are you going to
say next? Was Was moon sighting involved
in the moon sighting as well? Come on
let's not be ridiculous inshallah to
that degree inshallah. And it was
spotted minutes from country Sheikh put
this the bed inshallah. Brothers and
sisters let's make the most out of
Ramadan. Do not let Shaitan take the
blessings of Ramadan and the blessings
and get across Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
and start a new chapter. If you are if
you've been you know, not praying or
whatever it is, for Shaitan to make you
get caught up with this silly stuff,
inshallah. May Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
bless and preserve every single one of
you guys and protect you guys,
inshallah, and have a blessed Ramadan
and bring get close to Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala. Assalamualaikum Wa Rahmatullahi
Wa Barakatuh. Hopefully, this puts the
whole matter to bed.